自分の人生を振り返ってみて1番成長し
てる時は1番苦しい時なんですよ部下を
持たなければ人間としての成長はなかなか
難しいと思うよその大きな仕事をするため
にやっぱり組織が必要なんですよ青木サの
人生経営哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですねあのよく中間管理職は罰
ゲームであるという言葉が
増え
過剰可を背負うという構図になりがちで
この悪循環から脱するためにはなんか管理
職ってどうしたらいいんでしょうかという
ことについて社長の考えを聞かせいただけ
ますかなるほどそれは側ではなくて管理職
の人がどういう心構えでまたどういう風に
それに対して考えていたらいいかかなうん
わかりまし
[音楽]
た高い心ざしを持って将来やっぱり独立を
するとかもしくは自分が上に上がっていく
もっと言うとその上に上がってどんな
面白い仕事をしていくのかっていうもう1
つその高いレベルの心ざしというか
ビジョンがないと目の前の仕事だと楽な方
流れちゃうんだよ僕はねくと楽があったら
結果的に区の方を選んでるんですよいや
本当に若い時をそしてキャリアを形成した
その時はま自分の人生振り返ってみてねま
社会出て52年経ってるんだけど自分の
人生を振り返ってみて1番成長してる時は
1番苦しい時なんですよ1番苦しかった時
1番葛藤した時横綱千富のね引退記念の
プログラムを作ったんだけどこれが全く出
なかった時にまさに逃れられない状況に
追い込まれてま経営者としてもものすごい
こう負債というか不良在庫を持ってしまっ
てこの不良在庫をなんとしても売らなけれ
ばならないという大きな壁にぶつかった時
に僕の中に内在しているまさに眠れる趣旨
を目覚めさせよってやつよねむくむく
むくっと出てきたよねうわみたいなついに
出たかみたいな自分の中でこの横綱千のの
プログラムに英語の手帳をつけてそして知
を絞って研修の形で全部3000セット
売り切ったわけですよねそしてその時に
結果的にだよなんだろうな災い展示て服と
なるで売り切った後にそのエッセンスを
抽出してオリジナルのプログラムを作って
いたわけじゃないだからもしあの苦しい
時代がなければ今はないんですよだから僕
は常にそういう人生なんだよねだから逆境
があってその後その成長してるまあえて
言うならそういう苦しい状況を自分から
進んで作っていくそしてそそう自分を
大きくしていくってことだと思いますよね
子供を作るのもコスパが合わないとかさ
結婚するのもコスパが合わないとかさ
なんかこう今だけ金だけ自分だけみたいに
考えちゃうと正直負荷は置いたくないと
思うと思うんだよめんどくさいもんいや
もっと言ったら例えばだよもっともっと
恋愛を楽しみたいと思ったら結婚もしない
でずっと独身でいて思いっきり人生を王化
しようこれも1つの生き方として悪くは
ないと思いますよだけどだよやっぱり
子育てをして負荷を背負っていろんなこと
があるわけよでもその乗り越えて親は子供
によって育てられるんですよ逆に親として
そういう側面もあるのよそのもちろんね
独身であっても書体持ってもね結婚しても
それどちらでもいいんだけど今のは例え話
なんだけど部下を持たなければ人間として
のやっぱり成長はなかなか難しいと思うよ
というのは
かってまだキャリア浅いわけじゃんでき
ない人に対してできるように育て
るっていうことは愛情がないと諦めるよう
なだから自分の人間力がどんどん大きく
なるんですよでできない部下を当てがわれ
た時ほど実は自分は悩むし苦しむし葛藤
するしなんでこの程度のことができないの
とか色々思うんだよでマネジメンとの失敗
をしたり辞められたりいろんなことがある
んだよだけど成長してきました実際それ僕
だよねだから最初から経者になったわけ
じゃないもん最初は管理者だったわけだ
からでやっぱあっちぶつかりこっち
ぶつかりし
ながら真心を持って自分なりにやってきた
けどやっぱり自分軸で考えずにあやっぱり
もっと伝え方が良くなかったんだなとか
もう少し事前にに打ち合わせの時間を
買取ってあげた方がきっとここでこんな
思いをさせなくてよかったんだなごめんね
みたいな逆にこっちの方がこう人としての
あり方がその部下を育てていく中で自分を
成長させることができたっていう感じだよ
ねだからま是非その管理者の人にはね騙さ
だと思ってチャレンジしてほしいうんて
いうのは僕も昔ブリタニカでトップセルス
の時にやっぱりこうメンバーを持って組織
持ってやってみろて言われた時に一瞬
ふうっと思ったのよというのは楽じゃん
もう自由時在に営業だったらできるし時間
的にもある程度結果作れば何も言われない
とかあってでもあえて収入も下げてわかる
もう1番下のマネージャーでも1番見習い
みたいなマネージャーから入るわけじゃん
で数人育てていってでそれは自分だったら
簡単にできることをアポ1つ取るのも大変
なんだからそすとこのアポ取りを教えたり
で一緒に同行してあげて見せてあげてでも
育ったら大きいよだって今うちの会社さ
220人社員いるけどま経常利益ねま一応
20億を超える経常利益の会社になったよ
ね
これ1個人で僕はコンサルタントで一生
懸命頑張ってても逆立ちしても20億の
経常利益は出ないですよやっぱり組織なん
だよそして育成ができるから今のようにで
今僕はこの年齢になってタイムリッチです
よねもう本当にどんどん時間的にも余裕が
出てくるだ実際僕の今実動って2割ぐらい
じゃない全部の売上に閉める僕の生み出す
価値っていうのはまもちろんね
ブランディングだとかいろんなことで違っ
た意味で貢献はしてるけれど直接売上げ
作ってるのは2割ぐらいだもんあとは社員
みんなが作り出してくれているこれ管理食
の人たちもそういう風にもうちょっと
物差し長期的な物差しで将来やっぱり役員
目指すとかその上を目指していかないと
なかなか今の
にことはねあると思いますあとはもう1つ
はね会社の問題もあるのよあの大企業をね
がなんかもそうだし役職役付きにしてる方
が労働基準法から見てその制約がないとか
そういう姿を見て見通しが持てなくなって
しまってる人もいると思うのでだから会社
側の問題も一1つはあるので安にそういう
その目先の楽なことを会社も選んじゃだめ
だよねそうじゃないと憧れられる管理職に
ならなければ管理職なろうと思わないもん
時代はどんどん2極拡散なんじゃないかな
それからねもう1つ僕はあの今回すごく
思っているのはねAI生成AIの力を
使える会社が小人数でも大企業に迫る
パフォーマンスを出せるんですよだ
やっぱりそういうDXを含めた社員数の数
で戦う時代もう終わってるのねだから人数
少なくても非常に価値のある経営ができる
そういうAIを最大活用するとかだから
管理職でも人にね仕事を頼む時に無知は
コストで知らなくてできないことって
いっぱいあるからそういうまDX化を進め
るって生産性を上げると同時に生成愛なん
かも活用しながらより効果的な仕事をする
という管理職を目指していったらまあ
新しい時代の良い管理職になっていけるん
じゃないかなと僕は思いますけど
[音楽]
ねその組織で上を上に上がっていくって
いうことはその仕事の価値というか
やっぱり社会性というかその大きな仕事を
するためにやっぱ組織が必要なんですよで
やっぱり組織の上に上がっていかないと
権限持っていけないじゃないですかだから
そういう意味では心ざし組織の上を目指し
ていく中で自分を成長させてくれる1つの
課題としていろんな葛藤も自分から
やっぱりこうあえて自分がもう真正面から
その問題に向き合っていくで自分の人間力
を高めいくそういう風に考えていった方が
建設的じゃないかなという風に僕は思い
ますね楽なことに流されてしまうと
やっぱり長期的本質性客観的に見たら20
代30代40代ってその先の将来の50代
60代70代ここの本当に大事な時期なん
ですよここでやっぱり楽な道を選ぶよりは
部下を育てるという術を是非体得して
もらいたいという風に思いますね他の
YouTubeでもね色々伝えてますので
参考にしていただければと思います人を
育てるってね決して簡単なことじゃないし
確かに管理職にな
るっていうことは一見ね会社から与え
られる責任も大きくなるので負荷もすごく
かかると思うんですけど真正面から
やっぱり腹くくって3年5年しっかりと
自分の未来のために取り組んでもらいたい
という風に思いますチャンネル登録是非
よろしくお願いしますえまたコメント欄に
もね是非またコメントくださいまた次回の
YouTubeでお目に帰りましょう
ありがとうござい
[音楽]
ます負ない経営なのまず経営者自身がお金
よりも仕事の内容そのものに惚れ込んでる
かどうか
ないDET